with dignity and respect
committed to free speech and common
sense upbeat and entertaining straight
talking and direct we may act eight each
other and you thought-provoking
provocative and controversial hello and
welcome to the pledge the nation was
gripped last weekend as the England
men's cricket team took to the wire in a
thrilling victory at Lourdes lifting the
Cricket World Cup after a day packed
with drama nerves excitement elation and
of course our all-important champagne
super over they also kindly proved that
men are eventually capable of doing
everything women can just two years
later with a lot more drama a less
convincing result and a rather dubious
interpretation of the rules thanks chaps
Nick take note well women really do rule
the cricketing world coming up
Nick's saying the thin blue line is
fading away Rachel argues Gina Miller
has got it right Michelle wants more
trust in our media and Greg is talking
money money money but first it's me go
back to where you came from is perhaps
one of the oldest anti immigrant tropes
in the racist playbook a statement I
naively thought had been read from the
lexicon but this week none other than
the president of the USA decided to
bring this derogatory phrase back into
fashion with a series of racist tweets
targeted at for Congress women of color
there was only one problem these women
came from Detroit Cincinnati and New
York City and only one of them was born
outside of the US
unlike two of Donald Trump's three wives
or his mother it seems for the president
you're american-ness is only questioned
when you're not white even if you are
American perhaps the most disappointing
aspect of this whole sorry episode is a
lack of reproach from Republicans in
us and the refusal of two of the final
candidates for the Tory leadership here
in the UK to call out the tweets for
what they are racist it's a sad day in
British politics and in global politics
when the leader of the free world
resorts to dog whistle politics and
isn't even challenged by his own party
or closest international ally I mean
obviously you're right it's racist
doesn't mean anyone's gonna argue I
would possibly make my I'll come to you
no ma'am
but I think you're gonna look at why is
this happening and why is he doing it
and I think you've got to be careful in
your reaction to him we know what this
man is we knew it before he got elected
we knew that this is someone who's
deeply prejudiced sexist lazy all lovely
and he won right now well he didn't get
the majority of the votes but he won and
what he's trying to do is win again at
the moment he's behind in the polls to
most of the sleeting Democrats yeah and
this is one where I suspect his time to
cement his base I hope it means he'll be
savaged by everybody else but not now
let's wait until we get into because if
you do it now you bring the whole team
there and what it's trying to do is say
look the Democrats are basically
faithful for these four women yeah and
that's what he's trying to do and if
we're not careful it could work well
let's look at what he said and then I'll
come back to what you had to say so
these were the tweets so interesting to
see progressive Democratic Congress
women who originally came from countries
who government whose governments are a
complete and total catastrophe the worst
most corrupt and inept anywhere in the
world if they even have a functioning
government at all now loudly and
viciously telling the people of the
United States the greatest and most
powerful nation on earth how our
government is to be run why don't they
go back and help fix the totally broken
crime-infested places they from which
they came then come
and show us how it is done these places
need your help badly
you can't leave fast enough I'm sure
that Nancy Pelosi would be very happy to
quickly work out free travel
arrangements
amazing what is the world coming to
I'm glad that you read out the second
part because a lot of people didn't sit
now listen is Donald Trump a racist in
reality only Donald Trump and probably
his closest associates no does he say
racist things kidding me no some of his
policies racist yes does he say racist
things yes well there isn't that the
criteria of the one I don't know whether
the man himself is a racist but I'm glad
you read out the second part because he
does actually say this idea as you said
then come back and tell us how to do it
so there is that he's not booting them
out of the country it's it's ridiculous
in the in that three of them hold on
hold on if it's three of them were even
born in the United States now what what
he's seeking to do and we'll come to
your point what you've got to realize
here is that those four women don't
actually represent the Democratic and
they're actually bit of embarrassment to
the Democratic Party
I don't I neither Trump or his allies
have worked out that they are the target
by by effectively mobilizing the concern
against those four women he can start to
win backwards if he's going to be
President he can't just win on his core
vote he's got to attract the suburban
voters of that is exams where he tried
with the Catman it's not working this is
exactly what he's going to lose but
that's so so just coming back I'm glad
you said that they then come back
because that's been lost by a lot of the
mainstream
I think the end of it is irrelevant okay
and then just your plan just so that I
can summarize because you talked about
the reaction the two men who by this
time next week one of them will be Prime
Minister what do they say and you're
absolutely right they both had the
opportunity to say
and neither Boris Johnson talked about
being totally unacceptable in a modern
racial country or Jeremy Hunt who's
saying this is not the kind of language
the president of United States should be
using
Rachel interesting that you try and as
it were get Trump off the hook by saying
he's not a racist he he had the
president has actually said I didn't
have a racist bone in my body but he's
using racism as a platform to try to
instill a
so he's a sort of display racist which
sort of exonerates him from actual
racism I think that's nonsense with
respect now he has risen to the office
of the President of the United States
not on dog whistle but on loud
racism you know tolling Mexicans rapists
banning
folks traveling in from Islamic
countries you name it he's done it now
interestingly nick has a point because
he's had a bump there's been a Trump
bump his popularity has gone up what is
going to be interesting to see is if
America a country that was founded on
the principles and we are all equal
under God we're all equal under the law
whatever the color possibility of
immigrant whether that country allows a
president who is trying to divide the
country by up on with a race and
cultural war elects him again what we
know I mean if you wander around America
as opposed to going just to you actually
wonder where you know that there are
support for this view that's the wild
and it's reprehensible to use it so the
times before this program was take
Michelle the night before Trump was in
North Carolina at a rally and the chants
were build the wall and send her home
well we're gonna show that in a moment
and Michelle quickly but I want to bring
you in and then I have a video that I
want to show from one of the congressmen
in how she responded so I've changed my
view on this having seen what you've
just mentioned because when I first saw
this I thought it was a clumsily where
did tweet because to your point when you
say people have this view a view that a
lot of American people have is if you
don't love America and the way that we
do things then leave irrespective of
what color you are what age you are
where you come from where I come from
that is a view that a lot of Americans
hold and that is a view that Donald
Trump himself really does bang the drum
for and when I first read those tweets I
thought that it was just playing into
that narrative it was almost like if you
don't like these governments go over
there fix these governments then come
back it shows what I know from over
there that's
I know why I've changed my view is
because I saw that rally and I found it
so disturbing to watch they thought it
scanned our home Fender home can we have
a look yeah it was all falling
[Applause]
[Applause]
in in whipping up that sort of hysteria
he is putting a target on the backs of
immigrants throughout that country as
well as putting
Ilhan herself in danger and what he
needed there was to just say listen guys
that is not the language of the debate
we wanted to a responsible politician
was say I hear what you say that's not
the language of this debate but revels
in it but that's the language he won on
I can't your language you won last I
need in the midterms on that language so
we will see where America is by 2012 he
stands for re-election on a platform of
make America white again he should be
impeached yeah and then but where is the
mechanism and where is the will for that
to happen you're seeing the country the
rainbow nation becoming you know white
people probably hold on don't you think
if there's women instead of being a
Palestinian origin or Somalian origin
whatever he's focused on them for their
politics politics he's focused on them
because they are women of color and can
be deemed as other no that is why he's
focused he's focused on them because
they they seek he's seeking to show them
as proxy for the Democrat Party yes and
they're not and if they were white it
works to his ticket so he wouldn't care
if they were white Australians he wants
to paint them as because like I said
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders have
more or less radical as these fool they
are they are when it comes the financial
things that that could have been Germany
and then I just say we should he needed
to own that and say stop that's not the
language I want but that's the language
she wants because it's the language by
which he won last and I just want to
push back on what you said there Nick
there's a reason he has focused on those
four women Nick naming them the squad is
because they are visibly different if
they were white with those politics he
would not be focusing on them in the
same way not a squat
from that's what he's cool is that yes
I'm the lefty hit squad
can we have a look at what y'all
apprently had to say who is one of their
own super k it's not embody the grace
the empathy the compassion the integrity
that that office requires and that the
American people deserve I encourage the
American people and all of us in this
room and beyond to not take the bait
this is a disruptive distraction from
the issues of care concern and
consequence to the American people and I
think she's right they must not allow
him to set the agenda not that any of
this warrants what they're getting but
these aren't shrinking violets these
women was a point please don't think
they're four little retiring flowers and
can't quite warehouse happen to they
can't be as ballsy as anybody when they
choose but that's got nothing to no I'm
just seasoning they're American nurse
but don't paint them as victims but they
are victims because he's questioning
their American this when they are
Americans yeah I know I've been making I
have said that point over and over but
this is all about politics it's not yes
I I don't think I think it's client I
think this is what he want he said it
did it because actually your point is at
the beginning is dead right that what
he's trying to do is say this is the
damn these are the Democrats there yes
these four people who are who are very
low ranking in the past and on I am
fairly on the Left of the Democratic
Party they're the Democrats and that's
what he wants to do he wants to say
these are the Democrats you've got to
stop having them you've got to have me
yeah and allow that time to police this
debate